- Ah, beautiful, beautiful, beautiful.
- Am I beautiful?
- No.
(fun playful music)
- [Voiceover] Have you
ever cut hair before?
- Yeah.
- In second grade.
- I was trying to cut
out a tag on my shirt.
- (chuckles) And I found a
razor, and I went like this.
- And, I cut my front hair here,
because I didn't have
bangs, but I thought I did.
- And my mom saw me, and she's like,
"What did you do to your eyebrow?"
- Where'd all this hair come from?
- And, that didn't work out.
- [Voiceover] Do you think
it would be easy to cut hair?
- Well, if we're allowed
to go fun with it,
then yeah, it'll be easy.
- Hi. Oh. (giggling)
- I'm Tyra.
- Tyra, nice to meet you.
- So, do you want your hair done?
- I do.
- What kinda haircut do you like?
- I'm gonna leave it up to you.
- You know, I would
love a dramatic haircut.
- How bout a boy cut?
- Like a pixie?
- You gonna cut it all off?
- (mumbles) chopping your hair off.
- Okay!
Let's hope it's not my real hair.
- We're giving it to cancer, don't worry.
- Oh, okay.
- And, we're gonna make
this nice and short.
- I'm pretty sure I know what I'm doing.
- How's your day going?
- You know, it's good.
- Getting over a cold, but...
- Oo.
- Yeah, right, that sucks.
- (mumbles) the worst.
- Okay, then we're gonna
snip that, snip over here.
- Do you have a boyfriend?
- I do have a boyfriend.
- Can I steal it?
- (laughing) Oh my god,
so much is happening.
- She needed this, so
I'm glad she came in.
- Just gonna keep snippin', oh yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- Doin' fine.
- It's gonna be about 300 dollars.
- Whoa!
- Yeah, well we do a very good cut.
- I feel like there's
artistry happening behind me,
and I don't even know it yet.
- Well, perfection actually.
Perfection is happening.
- So, what kind of gossip is there?
- Listen, on Friday,
I stole a buncha orange
juice from this office.
- What?
- Your hair's way too thick.
Did your mom give you this hair?
- No, I know. I know, I know, I know, but.
- Why?
- How many boyfriends do you have?
- Only one.
- Then, you're not that
pretty. I'm just kidding.
(laughing) I'm just kidding.
- What's the hot gossip
at your office, buddy?
- There's this girl.
- Ooo...
- Well secretly, just between you and me,
she likes another guy.
- Okay, I don't think this is even,
but people's hair do not need to be even.
- (laughing) Oh, that was a close one.
I heard that one.
- Tyra, how many boyfriends do you have?
- I have four.
- Tell me everything.
What is the backstory?
- She's been like the love of my life.
- Alright, I can't wait til you see it.
- Your shirt's all hairy!
- We didn't have a, like a salon wrap,
or whatever those things are called.
- Because, you're poor.
I'm just kidding. (giggles)
- [Voiceover] Gonna get some bangs.
- If you cut the face off,
then they're probably not gonna pay you.
And, then you're gonna need a lawyer.
And, then you're gonna go to court.
- This escalated very quickly.
- I'm getting a lot of hair on me, Tyra.
- Then you go in the
shower and wash it off.
- Why didn't I think of that?
- Because, you have no brain.
- Wow!
- I'm just kidding.
- Is this how you treat
all your customers, Tyra?
- Okay, I think I got it.
- Ah, beautiful, beautiful.
- Actually, it looks kinda ugly.
- This hair, this hair!
- Ooo, nice.
- How much you gonna
pay me for doing this?
Like a hundred dollars?
- Eh...
- Ten dollars.
- Worth every penny.
- Present, the hairy Sophia.
- Yup. Free sweater.
- Oh, I'm beautiful. Look at that.
- Dude, this is so good!
- Thank you.
- Holy moly, look at this.
- Oh my good... Wow!
Actually, this isn't bad.
- I don't think this
is a bad look honestly.
I kind of look like Taylor Swift.
- Oh yeah, you do.
- Right?
- You look amazing.
- (laughing) This is actually
a pretty good haircut.
- Thank you.
- This is very modern.
This is very chic.
I see why you're so expensive.
Oh, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- What a wonderful haircut.
- I do, I will say that
I am covered in hair.
- (laughing) Okay.
- Here's Sophia!
Sophia! Oopsies.
Sophia! Boom, boom, boom!
- I would like that to play
whenever I enter a room, please.
Can someone record that?